okay
thank you for joining us our topic this
afternoon
is cnc programming made easy
with manual guide eye conversational
programming
part three creating a basic milling
program
without particular knowledge of g code
programming
it is possible to generate part programs
on the shop floor
by answering simple questions fanuc's
manual
guide eye conversational programming
provides this capability for milling
turning and mill turn centers with fanuc
cncs
part one in the series gave an overview
of the functionality of manual guide eye
part two built on that introduction by
reviewing the entire progression of
creating a basic
turning program with manual guide eye
today is part three we'll do the same
for a basic milling program
our presenter this afternoon is jody
michaels
as end user account manager for fanuc fa
america
jody michael's focus is on servicing and
supporting end users
to maximize their productivity with use
of fanuc cncs
jody has 35 years experience in the
machine tool industry
with various positions in sales support
automotive
applications and training at machine
tool builders
end users and cnc suppliers
he is a true expert on cnc programming
and the functionality
setup and use of manual guide i as we
listen to jody during the presentation
please feel free to share your questions
with us by typing them in the questions
pane on your control panel
he will answer those questions at the
end of the presentation
and keep in mind this webinar is being
recorded
so you will be able to view the entire
program online
later so again thanks for taking time to
be with us for the live program
here's jody
mark for that nice presentation for
uh for me and as as you said today we're
creating a basic milling program
and what we're going to do today is
we're going to pretend
and here's the part first we're going to
show the part that we're going to do
we're going to face it we're going to
drill it we're going to tap it
we're going to pocket we're going to
contour it
and this shows a representation of what
we're going to do
and but first what we're going to do
we're going to do a little bit of review
of what we did on the first two
because we're going to pretend today
that the machine that we're going to
start
working on is a machine just like you
would get
where it would not have any fixed forms
and tool data
so what we're going to do first we're
going to go through the process of
loading the fixed forms into the control
and then also our tool data
just like you would if you were getting
a machine that was fresh out of the box
and you just got it installed
so again this is the part that we're
going to do we're going to drill and tap
10 holes on the face we're going to do a
pocket
and then we're going to mill around the
contour so we got we're going to do
almost
everything that the milling cycles have
to offer
so at this point we're going to start
and what we're going to do we're going
to go into nc
guide just like we did before
and as i said what we're going to do
first we're going to go into the edit
mode
and typically when you go into the edit
the first screen that you would see
would be this where we'd start a new
program
but as i said what we're going to do
we're going to introduce
our fixed forms so if you go to the
right arrow key four times
and we get to a setting soft key
and today i've talked to several people
since we've done the first two
they said sometimes i do this and uh
too quickly so i'm gonna try to be more
leisurely in when i'm clicking on the
different buttons
so that you see the buttons that i press
each time
so right now we press the settings soft
key
and it brings you into this screen
register fixed form sentence from milli
and we select that and it takes you into
this screen
and see it still shows the fixed forms
that i had in there
but what we're going to do we're going
to delete this because if you press this
and this is a note of caution once you
get your fixed forms in there
you have this standard soft key if you
press that
so it comes up and says are you sure
current is overrided by standard
you press yes and what that does it
deletes all the fixed form
so don't press that button when you're
using
the manual guide i in your fixed form
and now what we're going to do we're
going to
put them back in we're going to press
input
and what it does it goes and finds any
files on your memory card that are
related to either fixed forms or tool
data
there's only two files so we select the
fixed form dot dat
which as we mentioned before this is
only a text file
this is something that you can edit if
you want on your own
but we don't want to open that right now
all we want to do is just
input it into our into our machine
repress input
and it says are you sure the current is
overrided by input
yes and it's three complete
then we close it and then see we have
our
fixed forms back we have form one form
two
form three i don't have any in form four
and form five is are in the program
so it's just that easy to import our fix
forms into that
and this is something that either your
dealer
your builder or fanuc itself can help
you with these
okay gonna get out of that you go to
menu
cancel and that takes us right back to
where we were before
now we're going to go through the
process of inputting the tool offset
we go into two offsets and see at this
point there is some tool data
but if you arrow over to tool data this
shows the list of tools that we
currently have
but at this point if we press right
shift
twice it brings these two soft keys
output and input if you want to bring
the information in you press
input arrow down to the tool
t-o-o-l-c-d dot file
and that's your tool data file tool data
backup file
you press input see it reads through
it's a little different from the tool
data it doesn't give you two buttons
where you have to push it twice
only once and then you close it
see now we have all of our tool data in
our machine
exactly the way i want and then also as
we said
we also have our fixed form we select
this
we've got all the fixed forms that we
need to help us build a program
so this is important that you know how
to do this
so at this point like i said to menu
cancel
now left shift twice three times
and we're right back to the screen to
where we actually start a program
so now at this point we're ready to
start our new program
so we get a new program and it asks you
for a new program number
and we're going to go 2 2 3 3 that's the
number i picked out
okay restarting the program now at this
point the first thing we want to do
we get to right check start
the first thing you want to do is define
a blank
we select that and since we're on the
machining center we're not doing round
parts anymore we're going to do a
rectangular blank
finger and again what we're defining
here
is only we're graphing most of this has
nothing to do with what
the actual machining is going to do this
is only for graphics for the simulation
we select that and you got six steel
that you need to fill out
you need to you have the width and we're
doing a six by six
by two inch block of mild steel
so we'll say six inches of width
six inch is the length the height is two
inches
now here this is just for the way you
dimension your park
now when i used to run a mill we always
when i was trained
we always made the middle of the part be
zero x y
zero so in order to come up with that
the one side will be three inches the
other side will be three inches
and the top of the part in z we're going
to say point zero three
thirty thousands because we wanna face
off just
a little bit off the top of the part at
that point we press the insert
soft key and it puts that blank
in the program and you can look down
here it tells you what g1902
is that's a rectangular blank figure
okay
so at that point we go to our fixed form
and the start lines that's what we want
to insert first
that has a tool change and everything
and where we had question marks it comes
down and says imperfect
word must be changed so we arrow up to
the first question mark
and it's asking for a tool number and i
know tool number eight
is the one that's our face now because
we're going to use a face mill first
eight go over to the b number which is
the
header compensation number eight again
until as soon as you do that with that
line
over here it tells you what tool that
we've called up
for face now all right so then we go
down
now that this line line number nine it's
a positioning move
again as we discussed before this is a
line that i always put in if when you're
reading the manual guideline manual it
will not tell you you have to do this
i always recommend that you do this just
so you know where it's going to go at
the beginning of those sites
so it's x0 alter
and y 0 alter
like i said that's just a clearance mode
now this line
again as we talked about this being a
teaching mode
see it tells you what the g43 is it's
tool length compensation
that calls up the length of the tool
and i always use as a clearance move one
inch for the z move
that's one inch above the part and again
the h that's our tool length
compensation number
again that's a alter
and again the diameter compensation
that's eight also
alter and for this tool we're gonna say
we're gonna run this at 750 rpm so we
put the cursor over the s word press
alter
and again you always want to maintain to
put a feed rate in there just to make it
act
so let's say 10 inches a minute alter
m8 then we'll turn on the coolant over
in the position
now at this point we go into our cycles
and what we're going to do first we're
going to do face machining
and it brings us up two choices either
rough or finished
and we're only going to make a minimal
pass so
we'll go down and say we're going to
finish we'll select that
and again it's just fill in the blanks
just like we did before
and it'll highlight what it's asking for
it says
cut depth of radio that could be a
little confusing but what it really
means is what
is a step over on that tool when we go
from
past to pass typically what you do is
one half the diameter
of the cutter this is a three inch face
nail so we're going to put 1.5
inch and a half and it asks for a feed
rate a linear feed rate so that's 50
inches a minute
and one inch per minute for the down
feed rate and
again it does highlight what it wants
so we put that and also
there's detailed data and we'll explain
what those are the cutting method
on the face when you're facing it you
can either have it
only cut in one direction which would be
single or zigzag
if you want to head both ways we're
going to do zig zag
since we're doing it both ways since
it's only a small cut this is what it
does
at the end of each cut you can either
have it pull up or stay down on the
part and this is just how it moves to
the next cut
if you put zero it wrap it to the next
cut and that's what i put in the r plane
is the hundred thousandths
like i always use the clearance of the
axis that's
how far it comes off the part 0.25
the direction i said right you get all
these
different selections down here right
left up and down
which direction it shifts and then just
the approach move to start the cut
we're going to say 3x so we've entered
in all that information
so we press insert and now at this point
it comes up and says okay what kind of
figures do you want to do while you're
facing
and we're doing a square part so we
select there
and again it's just fill in the blank it
says what kind of figure type we're
doing a face
the base position is z zero
the center point we decided that zero
and zero was our center points in x and
y we know it's a six inch long part
and six inches in y again the next two
they have asterix next to them you do
not have to answer that information
okay so we insert that
so those two lines of code that's the xy
square as you can see over here
the one before is our facing finish
those are the only two lines of code
that we need to do
spacing cut and as we did before
i like to simulate it as we do through
through each cycle
so at this point we go to auto
trim lat rewind
and start
so there it it milled the face of that
part just cleaned it out
the reason we have this alarm is because
we don't have it in the program
so but they did what we wanted to do so
at this point we got it first off
we go to edit we are down to the bottom
of the program so now we gotta talk
about another tool change it
but we need to get to a different tool
so we have fixed form
and the start lines again and we go back
and fill out our data
again so now this time we got to go
figure out what tool number is
for a chamfer let's talk about so we got
two offsets
we arrow over see down here on number
seven
it's a chamfer tool where it's flat
drill so we close so we know we gotta
use tool number seven so you have
seven alter
seven holder on the diameter
see as soon as we did that see now down
here it says chamfer tool
so we got the right tool again our
positioning move is x zero
y zero alter
our positioning move to pick up our two
length again it's via one inch
again that's my personal preference you
might wanna do something different i'm
all right with that however you wanna to
seven alter
seven holder on their header
compensation number
and now for this tool we're gonna run it
much faster we're gonna say 3000 rpm
just type in the 3000 as long as you
have the cursor over the s
word and press alter then a feed rate
again
10 inches alter
we've we've done everything to pick up
the tool length
start spindle turn on the tool so at
this point we're going to go to another
cycle
we go to our cycle health key
and we're going to do center drawing we
select that
and again it's still in the blanks
you've got two different types you can
either have it normal where it just
cuts in rapids back out or you can have
a dwell where if you wanted to
make a good round spot you can do that
for the dwell
so we're gonna do normal and then
for positioning to start doing these you
can either have initial one or initial
two that would be like if you had
clamps or something on the table that
you want to rise up above
you can do that but we're going to use a
reference position which is like the r
plane
then it asks for a cut depth and we're
going to go minus 0.375
our r plane is 0.1
our feed rate is 25 inches a minute and
our move to start this is
a three axis move so we press enter
now you'll notice as soon as we did that
so that was our cutting condition
then it comes up and says okay what are
the points that we you actually want to
spot throughout
you've got all these different
selections random linear points
and there are points different intervals
grid points rectangles circles
what we want to do right now is a
rectangle we'll select that
and again it's just filling the blanks
our base position in b is zero
the start point in x is minus two
and minus 2 and y now it says okay
what's the length for this pattern we're
doing in x
so it's 4 inches and the length in y
is 4 inches also so we're doing a square
we want
two holes in each
each line and we insert that and then
also
we have another tab up here you could
also have it skip holes if you want
it would be in the same same pattern
but we don't want to do that so we press
enter
so there's our rectangular rectangular
point
but i also know that we want to do a
circle a full circle also so we can do
that at the same time if we go under
our figure soft key
we parallel down and then under
rectangle we have circle points
so we select that and again the base
position
z is zero our center point in x and y is
zero
and zero the radius that we want to do
is one
point five the start
point angle is zero and we want six
holes
okay and again we have the skip if we
want to skip holes but maintain that
pattern
you can do that but again it's got
asterisks you don't have to answer that
so we insert that information
and again like i said we'd like to go
back and simulate everything we've done
so similar rewind
then press start okay goes and faces it
that goes in spot drills all those
very simple very simple so now at this
point now we want to drill those holes
okay so we go group off go back to edit
and again just like we did before we
have to go back to our fixed form
and put the start lines in again and
we'll go back
and highlight the p number
again we're drilling a hole for a 3 8
16 tap so we under our two offset so
that
the radius of that tool will be 156.5
one five six five so that's two number
one if we arrow over
that's the drill but we need to the
number one this one
so one also
one holder there see as soon as we do
that
it comes up okay it's a drill that's
what we want
our position move is zero
and over in x and y
the positioning movement z is one inch
and then it's h1 is our true length
and c1
now this two will work again we're going
to run this at 3500. we got a good solid
carbide drill
and our feed rate is 10. again this is
just
making it active again emanate is
turning on cooler
so now we're going to go back we're
going to do a drill site
so we get our cycle softkey
arrow down to drilling select that
and again we got four different choices
here we got
normal well tech and high speed
okay those are our different selections
so what we're wanting to do here is
normal
it will draw all the way to depth to
come out dwell to drill
depth and then stop hacking it'll go
into a far into a full retract
high speed that's for it'll drill so far
and stop like a chip brake type
we won't do pecking pecking cut depth
that's how far it will go in
each cutting move so we're going to say
0.5
again the reference point mode you've
got three choices we're going to use the
r plane
our cut depth is minus 2.5 because we
want to make sure it goes all the way
through the part
the gopass amount that's to allow for
the angle on the end of the drill
0.1 the clearance move is 0.1 that's
about the part
i always use 0.1 there's our feed rate
and then the positioning move will be a
three axis move
then you have detail again it has
asterisks here you don't have to answer
all that information
this would be like if you had a big
drill where you wanted to start it out
slowly until it's got
the drill fully engaged you can do that
and then also at the end you can have it
slow down at the end
but again it has an asterisk you don't
have to answer that information
so we insert that see as soon as we do
that again it comes up where it wants us
to define the point
but we've already done this before so we
don't need to fill these out again so we
press cancel
and we're going to arrow up where we
just did our pattern
rectangle points and circle points so we
want to copy this
so we press copy it says define the
range we want those two
copy and we arrow down in the program to
where we just defined the drill cycle
press paste it always paste it
underneath whatever you have the cursor
over
okay so it puts as circle points
and rectangle points right after the
drilling cycle we just did
so now we can go animate what we just
did we didn't have to fill all that up
twice trim that rewind
sorry there's our face mill
there's our spot drill now we have a
small drill that goes in and drills all
the holes
all ten holes
okay and we didn't have to go through
and redefine
the pattern because we already had that
we just had to copy it and redo it
let's paste it back in so at that point
we'll
press group off go back to the edit mode
very down to the end so now at this
point i want to tap the six holes in the
middle
okay so again we have to go
to our fixed points insert the start
line
and we want to go up to i know this time
it's tool five it's a path
so we have five alter
five alter on that so as soon as we do
that it comes up it says it could tap
i've only got one tool one tap in the
tool data
so i know we're correct there so it's
zero
for our positioning move and x and y
i know we're going over and over again
this over and over again but
it's good practice again our uh
approach point for z is one inch
and the h word again that's our two
length compensation that's one
and then five alter
then five and holder on this also now on
the tap you're not gonna run it as fast
so we're gonna take 250.
okay then a feed rate will just prepare
and like i said this is just to make it
accurate
now we're going to go into a cycle again
now this time we're going to do tapping
we haven't done this one before yet
select and again it's still in the
blanks
you can either do a normal which would
be a right-handed thread reverse would
be a left-hand thread
we're going to get normal floating path
and like i said it's a 16 pitch thread
if you wouldn't know what that lead was
if you go 1 16
enter it does the math for you so that's
0.0625 lead
the r plane our cut depth is
minus 1.5 our clearance is 0.1
no dwell time and then a three axis
positioning then we press insert
and again it takes us into where it
wants us to define the points again but
we don't have to do that
because we want to arrow up and all we
want to do is a circle
the xy circle points here
we want to copy that
only that one and go down to our drill
tapping cycle and paste
you see it pastes it right after that
so at this point we can go simulate
again
we go to auto sim lab
rewind and start
and now at this point it will go through
and simulate all that
so at that point it went through and
simulated
the entire part
we're well on the way to finishing
everything we want to do
okay again we got the end of record
um alarm so we go group off
and that's this way we go back to edit
and again we gotta go to fix
forms again and add in our start lines
again
and what we wanted to do this time we
got a mill a pocket in the middle of the
part
so again i'm not i think it's cool too
but i'm not sure
so we've got a two offsets the arrow
over
number two is a flat end mill that's
what we want
so we go look at that and it's a half
inch diameter flat in there
that's what i want so it's two three two
holder d2 holder
yeah zero and x and y is our positioning
move
so we need to change that the g43
z is one inch
he has two on h 2
2 on the d word and now this time we're
in that's pretty fast to 2000 enter
good solid carbide in there 10 inches
for the feed rate
like that now
we're going to go into a different cycle
this time another one that we have not
done yet
here we during the go
and we've done whole machining we've
done face machining now we're going to
do pocketing
so we are over to that and we can do
pocketing rough
that's what we want to do we select that
and again it's still on the blacks first
to have asterisks next to them
if you don't put anything there it's
going to assume
that it's a solid part like what we have
or if you're only removing minimal stock
you could tell it how much stock on the
sides and on the bottom but we're not
going to do that
cut depth of radius again this is just
like on the facing cycle
it's asking for the speckle we've got a
half inch diameter
tool so we're going to use half of that
0.25
and if you wanted to do the math you
could say 0.5 divided by 2
and do the math for you the cut depth of
axes that's the depth of cut
we're going to set point one we're not
going to leave any finished stock we
want to
mill it to size and then the feed rate
we're going to say 25
25 and one inch down
okay that's all you need in that path
you also got detailed data you either
got
up cut or down cut this would be like
climb cut or conventional cut
i don't know why they don't say that but
that's what it is
the clearance of the axis that's how far
it backs off when it's milling
the pocket how far it backs off the side
i'll put 20 000. our hard plane is 0.1
the approach is three axes and we can
either have it
go straight in or healing for it
either way i'm just going to say for
what we're doing here straight for a 20
degree angle
we insert that and it comes up and says
okay what are we going to do here
i want to do an xy circle
okay so we select that
and again it's very simple just fill in
the blank the concave
pocket the base position
is zero enter that the height is minus
0.5
and again that's one of those where as
you're looking at this drawing
it wants you to put a plus or a minus
if you wanted to go down you're going to
use a negative
if you don't put it make a minus it will
assume it's plus
okay the center point is 0 x and y
and the radius is 0.75
okay then we insert that
all right so at this point let's go
simulate that
to make sure it's going to do what we
thought we told it to do
rewind and start
so it faces it up drills
there's our drilled holes
i've tapped all the six holes in the
middle
now we got an end mill going through and
putting a round pocket
in the middle okay so now at this point
we've got that done we also want to go
through
and add milling around the outside of it
we can use the same tool because it's
big enough it's strong enough to do that
and what we want to do now is go right
shift
and edit right shift
we won't go cycle and what we want to do
now
we're going to do contouring
outer wall contouring and we only want
to do
finishing because we're only going to
take minimal stock off the size we only
want to clean it up
so we select that and again it's just
filling the blanket says okay how much
stock are you going to take off the
outside
we're going to take off 25 000.
and we're not going to leave any for a
finished path we're going to ask for
feed rates we're going to say
15 inches a minute for the first tail
then one inch on the downward and the
detail data
again it's either up or down code
the clearance the our heart plane is 0.1
and we're going to arc on an arc off so
it gives you three choices you can
either feed down vertically
park on or come in at a tangent
so it gives you a lot of choices so
we're going to arc on
a quarter inch radius at a 45 degree
and then we're going to have a 3-axis
move for the approach
so we insert that and again it comes up
and says okay what are we going to do
here
okay so this time what we're going to do
is
we're going to do this the square select
that and again it's convex
we're going to do around the outside
that's the figure type
our base position in g is zero
the height is a two inch part but we're
grabbing hold on those with a vise
about an eighth of an inch so we're
going to go minus 1.875
the same point zero zero
the length is six minus
0.050 so it does a figure important so
it's 5.95
and we're going to put a corner radius
of one two five
okay and the parts in there straight so
we don't have to tilt it
so we insert that so just for those two
lines they'll contour the outside of the
part
so we go back to auto
trim that three lines
inside now it should do everything it
should end up like the picture we showed
you at the beginning
drilling all the holes
tapping all the holes milling the pocket
in the middle
okay so then it went around the outside
you can see
on the corners here but the radius is
like what we wanted
and then also just to show you what you
can also do
for the simulation we're going to rewind
now this time you can't rotate it around
so we can reverse it
let's see what that does it lets you
look at it apart from behind
and see if the holes drill all the way
through
and see if it's going to show the tools
on the other side
there's our spot drill here comes our
drills
see how it's showing that the hole is
actually drilling all the way through
now you can see the white or drills all
the way through
so it's very handy for that
see now it's in the pocket in the middle
and it'll show tool going all the way
around the outside
and see how it shows these these green
lines here that's shown to where it's
just barely clean enough
so at that point we're getting our alarm
at the end
we go group off we go to edit what we
want to do now we want to
add or in the program so we go right
shift
and end and number fours are in the
program
if we add that
now we've got a full program so what we
want to do now we're in edit
we get right chess you want to simulate
it again
with everything in it you want to rewind
because what we want to do here is we
want to add the time size
you press start it goes through and does
its thing
all the way through the program again
okay there's it's tapping the holes
installing the pocket in the middle
okay when it does the outside and there
it's done
and then if we get a right shift from
there
we have a false key that says insert
and say machine time data is inserted
okay
yes see it puts time
if we give it our the list in time
to make that part it's currently eight
minutes and eight seconds
it's got 12 seconds of non-cut time
which is frankly pretty aggressive
called you know it
you have to put times in there to tell
it how long it takes to do a tool change
but again you can use us to do time
studies also
so now at this point we've got all that
done and now say
we've already cut apart all right we're
happy whether they came out the way we
wanted
so we say group off and what we want to
do at this point
we won't go to auto because now we want
to convert it to a decode program
okay go do that out of auto right shift
nc convert soft key
and two two three four is our new number
okay press start
and what it's doing now it's going
through and converting what we just made
in conversational into a g-code program
and this program you can take from
this machine if you had other machines
with standard controls that did not have
manual guide eye in them
you could take it out of this machine
and put it in another machine
and run it because it's just straight
g-kit stuff
but anything control will read
okay we'll see like right now it's doing
the
the pec drills he uses a g83 for that
that's just a standard drill cycle for a
fan and control
or for a variety of machine
okay now it's getting ready to go
through and do the tapping
and on the tapping it'll just use a g84
you know that's something that you're
used to seeing
so if you'd rather run it off of this
you can do that
and that's what we're doing right now
we're converting this to a g-code
program
we'll wait to see it finished but i just
want to briefly show you what
the gk program looks like
almost done now from the last tool okay
so now it's done
if we return out of that and we go to
edit
and now at this point we have two two
three three of the the original so we go
down to two two three four
open that and then we can page down
through it
and what it does it takes the original
conversational cycles and put
those in parentheses but then it
converts everything else to gta
okay and as i said like in the drilling
cycles
it'll use cycles just like what you're
used to use
you'll see like for the spot rail uses
the g81
and it tells you what a g81 is and what
all the different
things in a g81 are
and then also for the where we drill the
holes all the way through
it uses a g83 and again it explains
to you what all the g the different
values in a g83 cycle are
so it's very nice for teaching you what
the g codes mean
so at that this point that's what
everything that i wanted to do today
so at this point we're going to go back
to our
presentation and
we'll go back to mark and we'll move on
okay over any questions you might have
it's back to you mark
okay thanks judy that was really
interesting it was a
informative presentation fact all three
parts of the series have been really
good so
congratulations i'm i'm glad i could be
a part of this
um so we do have some questions from our
audience so we'll get started with those
in the meantime please feel free to
submit your own questions
by typing them into the question pane on
your control panel at the right of your
screen
and we'll get answers for all of your
questions even if we don't get to them
or on the air
the webinar is being recorded and it'll
be available online so if you can't stay
for the whole session you can catch up
later
so let's start with our first question
here
when i convert the conversational
program to a g-code program how do i
adjust
cutter comp in the g-code program
okay there there is a parameter
for if it uses
g41 or 42 you can
turn on that parameter where it does
that then you just go into your wear
offsets and your tool offsets
and adjust it there whether it's you
know to make it smaller or bigger
so that's how you do that more okay
all right another question here is
uh how do i plunge down when
i am milling an outside contour it seems
to only
wrap it down well
that's where you know we just did that
on the last cycle
and on it you have three different
choices you can either have it
uh go down and see just straight down
or you can have it come in arc in
or tangent in evidently it's probably
using where it's just
coming right straight down in z that's
probably the issue
you need to use the arc on and the arc
off
because then it will feed on to the
outside contour
right um
question here is can you purchase the
desktop
version for business use
did you get that question i'm not
exactly sure
yeah you can with ncguide
you can get a version that you can put
on a laptop or a desktop
where you can actually have manual guide
eye within it
yes it is possible to do that
okay another question here
with castings i work above the z
0 quite a bit how does that work in
milling cycles
and drilling are all z values absolute
or
are some incremental
well with um you know when we do
drilling cycles
it asks you for how you want to approach
it there's
either initial one initial two or the r
plane
so with the initial one and the initial
two those are incremental values
above the part
i think that okay okay
um new question how does this work with
programming a facing head on
an hbm the horizontal boring wheel i'm
assuming
i'm not sure it means for that what what
like doing facebook
i assume that's what it means it's
facing me yeah okay
horizontal yes yeah you can
horizontally yeah yeah you can set it up
with any type of
configuration it's just that i sort of
picked out a vertical machine
but you could set it up like a
horizontal
also so it would simulate it just like a
and there's a lot of different setups
that i mean because i know on a lot of
horizontal boring mills like you would
run the coil out
that's like a w dimension for w
axis so but it is capable with manual
guide eye to set it up with that
but again that's for our somewhere down
the road for our one of our next
webinars where we wouldn't discuss that
but it is possible to do that
okay good we've got some more questions
here from the audience
um here's the question can you speed up
or slow down the simulation playback
yes on the newer software probably on
what people are getting on machines
today there is a way that you can
slow it up with speed
yes you can do that obviously on
the machine itself mark the simulation
will be
slower than what it is like on if you do
it on a laptop or a desktop it's much
faster
than what it is on the actual control
okay
all right um another attendee's got this
question
what is the parameter to turn on the
cutter comp
what is oh to be honest i'm not sure
right off the top of my head
but if they send me that question in
i'll get them i'll get them that answer
i don't know what it is okay okay but
but obviously there is a parameter i
mean you can do that
yes there is because what it does mark
just
a little bit more explanation of that
either way that you do it
it looks at the diameter of the tool and
the wear offset
but only one of them doesn't actually
turn on a g41 or a g42
you have to turn it on to where it
actually puts that in the program
both ways it cuts it it still looks at
the diameter of the tool
okay good um got
some nice questions here another
attendee wants to know
wouldn't it be wise to eliminate the d
word on drilling and tapping
i'm not sure maybe you get a better idea
what that's asking
well it won't it won't really affect
that because that
it would only call that into
consideration
if you were using uh
you know if you were contouring with it
because if you're drilling and tapping
you're just going down in one
one direction so i don't think it would
be an issue
i don't think it would be an issue okay
uh another question can you program
a davis head for a horizontal boring
mill
with manual guide eye
you might have to i'm not sure if
there's parameters to make that work
but we can possibly set something up in
a fixed form
to make it work mark and that's what's
good about fixed forms
you know things that we can't allow for
parameter wise
sometimes we can put something in a
fixed form to make that work
okay good um some more good questions
coming from our audience
um can you edit the fixed format
to read whatever you want right so
instead of changing
x and y to zero every time on start just
have it automatic
uh
yeah yes you could probably do that if
you
make that a fixed point
yeah future today all right
um all right let's see here um
is the stimulation speed based on speeds
and feeds i guess those are the program
speeds and feeds
well when it simulates it and figures up
a time cycle
yes it looks at whatever feed rates you
have but
if you slow down the feed rate in the
program it will not slow down the
simulation i think that's what they're
asking
okay all right um
right here's another question can you
program
a thread milling cutter with manual
guide eye
yes yes you can
okay and there is a thread milling
feature
yes okay um let's see where we got here
um how do i make the tool
show up during simulation
well that's where i have the d word
when i do a tool change if you don't put
a value
in the geometry for the radius of the
tool
and then call it up in the program it
won't show a tool
it'll actually show it doing something
but it won't actually show a tool itself
so you have to have a value in the
geometry and call it up for that keyword
in order for it to show
all right how about um
can you pipe tap in manual tied eye
yes yes yes you can
i mean that's all a matter of up you
know
and i've probably the reason they asked
that was
you know while that's based on the type
of machine and how powerful it is how
fast
you're going to run it but you need to
know the
the depth to pipe tap and you
obviously have to know the pitch of the
threads on your pipe tap
but you're going to know that so yes you
can pipe that
okay another question about
threading is thread repair a standard
feature
with manual guide eye
yes you have thread repair and manual
guide eye
however and you know this is on the way
usually
yeah but yeah that's your hat you have
to have
some ladder support from the builder we
offer it on manual guide eye
but if the builder does not put it in
the ladder and it's for
thread repair it won't work so it's sort
of uh
you know it's got both sides have to
make it work
we have it on our control the elder has
to make sure his machine supports it
yeah well i mean that's pretty typical
with uh conversational programming
systems generally isn't that
yes yeah yeah it's usually it'll be on
there but
the builder has to make sure that their
ladder supports that
okay okay that sounds good all right how
about can i do a mirror image
yes you can yes you can and especially
there's several different ways of doing
it because
here recently i did it for a customer
where we put it in a fixed form
the g 51.1 turns it on
g50.1 turns it off and then you tell it
which
which axes to rotate around and also
when you drop go in and draw a free form
shape
there's also a mirror image option there
where it does the same thing
so if you did a pocket on one side then
you wanted this mirror image and on the
other side you could do that
so it's very easy very but you can do
that
all right here's another good question
i'm glad came from the audience
um can you use a probe with manual guide
eye
yes yes there are very powerful probing
cycles
within the right eye and with those you
can use both a tool setting probe mark
and also a spindle crown but it's
something that
you know you just don't it's a little
bit more in-depth setting that up
i mean you know it could help possibly
take you a day to get everything set up
for that
so you know you have to calibrate the
probe and everything like that it's not
something you throw in there 15 minutes
later you're probate
yeah but really works very well oh yeah
sure probably has a lot of benefits so
it's probably worth the effort for those
who can see that
um i've got a couple more questions here
so i'm gonna try to get through these
um okay do i have to fill in the data
for a bolt circle
over and over no
no just like we did today what i
typically do is
you know like if you're drilling
drilling and tapping you know once you
do it once you can just go back and
paste it in over and over again
so it makes it very quickly very quick
and i know today while we went through
it seemed like i was
doing it slowly but once you get used to
this you could
drill and pout the hole you can make the
whole program in two or three minutes
i mean it's very quick very quick
okay some more questions come in here
can you
set up multiple datums and can you cut
and paste the program
for multiple datums
yes yes yeah i guess they'd probably
talk about using like
you know different like g54 or g55 or
whatever
yes if you can do that and then you can
just go
cut and paste the cycles you want to do
it different levels
you can do that yes it is possible to do
that
all right another basic question here
from the audience
is the d offset half the tool
now assuming that's the diameter offset
one half of the tool
yeah it's the radius of the tool yeah
the green okay
i know i kept saying diameter but that's
just the way i
reference the d word in my mind i always
say diameter but actually i mean the
radius
on the mill all right okay
um another question here you know a lot
of good questions mean it was a good
presentation here i'm always glad to see
this
when milling a free form can you mill
only
from point a to point b or does it have
to be a complete
box it is
pop calls it there are
cycles within the contouring part
where it's only a partial contour so yes
you can just in a straight line
yeah that's the answer okay all right
um i think we can get these last couple
questions in
does the software allow for the size of
the tool
in the tool table yes it does
yes and that sort of goes back on the
question you know we answered earlier
markware was asking about tools who
knows radius comp
because while it looks at it regardless
of whether you turn on fuel mode's
radius comp with a g41 or g42
it does look at whatever data you put in
your tool offset table
so that's again you know it ties into
where we talked about it's important
that you get the right data in that
table
yeah okay okay good i'm gonna squeeze in
one more question
here uh uh jody uh how do i make the
machine
make the tool length active
okay you use that and we showed that
over and over today
but you use a g43 and what that does is
you give it a g43 with a move in
whatever axes that you're wanting to
compensate for but
typically you'll have g0 g43
z one inch with an h word the h
word picks up the tool offset tool
length okay
okay that's always good yeah it's always
good to reinforce that point
okay um looks like
we're about out of time so jody um
thanks again for presenting your slides
and
answering our questions i think it went
really well you know for those attending
this afternoon session
you can contact fanuc fa america if
you'd like more information
contact information is on the screen
reminder if you missed part one
or part two of this three-part series
you can find it on our website
mms online under the webinars tab
and we really appreciate the time you've
taken
with us this afternoon and hope you
found it
worthwhile i know i've enjoyed these
presentations so
thanks to everyone for taking part and
my thanks
also to those who arranged this session
and helped it go smoothly
this concludes our webinar